thank you
[Music]
he's obviously an article for Nick is it
yeah all right dude I don't like when
you guys say that because I feel like
the article is sad hey what do you think
about UFC champ Sean O'Malley I'm a fan
yeah I'm a fan yeah why are you a fan
you like everything about him
I like that uh he cheats on his wife all
the time I like that that's a real man
huh does he really
he claims he is entitled to cheat on his
wife because he quote pays for
everything oh sounds like a real man
yeah sounds like a real man and me as a
beta cook I think that guy sucks yep hey
uh is he Irish O'Malley that sounds he's
from Arizona
oh Riley not old parts that was pretty
good
uh I just bought some windshield wipers
the other day did you did it all for you
I needed them yeah that's good that's
perfect I think that's the Irish
oh
rally [__] oh I know such a stupid
concern
I need to get new windshield wipers
the beads of water stay everything was
flapping around Anthony do you need
Anthony it's your turn do you want new
windshield wipers uh I think I replaced
them like a year and a half ago so I'm
cool for now you know what do you get
new tires and they're like hey do you
want to add some wipers in there I'm
like don't try to upsell me please dude
when I'm driving like it up it kind of
goes to the right a little bit I should
probably get an alignment yeah probably
yeah I do like the feeling of getting
new tires I think we're ready they've
already clicked away so we can start
that
that's how we filter out people yeah so
so how do you feel about that he for
real controversially suggested that he's
allowed to cheat on I think you're
entitled to cheat on your wife if she
lets you and it sounds like she lets
them is that called cheating anymore
though no it's just like open
relationships yeah it's just being Y2K
compliant yeah is it cheating
if it's an understanding yeah it's just
an open relationship but is it opening
is it open relationship if she's not
allowed but is that power dynamic
because you pay for everything and she's
not set up in a way to leave comfortably
but does she how about this does she
agree
is she like hi I agree do we know her
her thoughts her opinions yeah what does
it say anything are you saying it live
on TV like that's like she seems like
she's compliant with that and yeah they
share a three-year-old daughter so it's
like it's kind of they're in you know
what I mean like and I feel like just
athletes in general they just do have a
different lifestyle especially the
fighting sports that's normies you know
or even like the NBA right yeah yeah
because they have like a lot of wives
and a lot of kids you don't have to say
it like that though like I pay for
everything therefore I can cheat like he
has an understanding with his wife why
is he got to be out there saying like
yeah like why does he justify it through
like I think it's I'm the breadwinner
You Gotta Throw it under the bus I don't
think it's an understanding I think it's
like you don't have a choice and if you
want to leave
good luck wait is it also uh a thing
because I think I saw an article a while
back where
um was he like on Tinder or something
like he had an actual profile so I think
people so people are like wait why do
you have a profile if you're married and
maybe this is his answer to that other
it's a stupid answer because all he had
to say is yeah I I'm very lustful yeah
that's a smart answer because whenever
he's on like podcasts or something
people always bring this up
it's a point of conversation a lot for
him yes this is what he said on a
podcast stupid thing to say is like I
pay for everything therefore I own this
[__] and I can do whatever the [__] I
want that makes you look like a piece of
[__] this is exactly what he said he
said I'm a king I pay for everything I'm
a king who starts off a sentence that
way professional fighters then he says I
treat Dania his his wife like a queen if
I get a little
on the side what does that have to do
with anything I have testosterone
running through my oh so he's just an
old school Emperor yeah with the with
the with the horde of concubines yeah I
think it's unfortunate but like yeah
that's that's one of the bad side
effects about being the guy that pays
for everything you think you're entitled
to like Liberties at the same time I
feel like this like zooming out a little
bit more it is people like this that
makes GSP look so good you know because
he's like he's like traditional Warrior
Samurai like I have my code and then you
kind of need this like Duality there's a
heel yeah you're like oh I like this guy
because he's this and then there's this
crazy dude that say crazy [__] and he
has like snow cone hair and all that
like he's just a crazy character he
looks nice he's got 69 titled on them
somewhere the number 69. that's sick
that's a pretty good number I wonder if
he does that a lot with the girls he
cheats with
but like you said it's such a standing
69 yeah yeah girl holding Guy where he's
being held by her cheating is such a
weird term for what he's doing though it
really is and it's yeah why do you have
to say that out loud it just you know it
just makes his lady I'm sure everyone's
like wow you know let your man talk feel
like that it just seems like that's the
benefit of living a life where you don't
have to pay for anything it's like you
have to be accepting that your man is
gonna cheat or do whatever he wants is
he just pulling a McGregor though and
just getting a lot of eyeballs and
attention and [__] he might be that's
his game though like if in the in the
MMA game he is very good at doing that
like that is the set like he's he's
really good at being uh polarizing and
everyone's face like he's always in the
news people always talking about three
comments all the time it definitely
works like we're all talking about it
everyone starts talking about it I could
see that he just became the champion so
maybe he doesn't even cheat imagine
that'd be a tight move because I'm
thinking like dude if I was there if I
was that guy I would definitely open
every sentence with I'm okay that's
funny as hell yeah that's true because
you definitely get different Liberties
as a professional MMA fighter it's like
the it's like the um America guy how his
career was eh and then he became super
America Trump guys yeah yeah and
everyone started talking about him more
everyone was talking they were gonna cut
him that night until he called Brazil
like you guys are a [__] dump you
guys are all a bunch of dogs and they're
like you know what you're part of this
company
what a [__] promo this guy knows how
to Market yeah yeah what do you think of
the idea that like because you pay for
everything there's certain things that
you should get to do without any um
agreement or not
do whatever you want with purchases
you're talking about in general yeah
like if for uh General relationships
yeah like if we were in relationships
where literally we paid for every single
thing all of it yeah do we get to have
uh Undisputed decisions with our wives
no no [__] away
except for this tattoo see how paying
for everything
justifies [__] someone else's in the
mouths
entry every time it's a theme today okay
mouth [__] right I mean [__] tend
to come before the [__] [__] for me to
do for me the damn will do
percentage-wise well I'm paying for sure
you just make it sound like the other
person's asleep or something yeah not
not in my relationship I also feel like
it's a
regardless of who brings in what it's a
team
together and then people are bringing in
different things to the group so it
might be monetary so it might be
emotional or whatever like everyone has
their currency that they bring in right
but then we have to make decisions for
the betterment of the team and we
already know Bart doesn't bring in any
emotional currency
that's very true
leading a fleeting amount yeah so I
don't get to make any emotional
decisions ever I guess it depends on how
much you come out of that ties the
relationship so some people see it as
more transactional and others see don't
really see the that in the same way like
the value system in the same way where
some people don't keep track of the
money and other people do I think it
just depends but uh you should probably
talk about this before going into it
that's a good idea it seems so old
school like it reminds me of those old
movies where like a dude is cheating and
then the wife finds out and she's like
trying to leave and he's like where are
you gonna go Blanche where you're gonna
go Blanche you know what I mean like
it's like it is true you kind of have
someone at a Stranglehold like in that
way that part sucks and then she says
she can't really leave it's true yeah
but even in traditional relationships
adultery or infidelity is like
illegal
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I don't know in
what culture it was okay yeah it's wrong
yeah
um well what's Sean o'nally O'Reilly
says uh is that he he has he has
previously spoken about their quote open
relationship uh he said everyone's
definition of an open relationship is
different I like to think of ours as
just an open-minded relationship where
we don't own each other I don't own her
and she doesn't own me then it's not
cheating because she's probably [__]
then has nothing to do with what he pays
for the money it's just an agreement
just being in Sunday or yeah right so
when I first met Dania I told her I
don't know why anyone would [__] the
same chick for the rest of their life I
can't do that so she knew she wasn't in
love with the phony me we've had some
dope threesomes every relationship
should be okay with that that just needs
to happen some dope or something that's
cool that's cool if that's your
agreement there's nothing wrong with
that but to tie it in with like how much
you pay for is just it's like it's kind
of like that top G mentality of like
you're entitled to it like you're not
entitled to it you're entitled to
whatever you agreed on that's yeah
that's the right way yeah the way they
paired the sentences up it's weird it's
like oh I could beat her up so I could
cheat anytime I want oh that's a good
but it's like why actually wait
technically
National fighter bro why did you put
those two sentences like stacked
together like that that's weird but Nick
what's the beta cuck uh version of this
just she my wife pays for everything so
she gets to [__] whoever she wants
that's that's pretty good and I get to
listen for my cooking I get to be in my
closet and watch him
um yeah I think that'd be a good
Solution that's my answer